well Natasha grename joins us from West
Jerusalem with more on the crisis in
Israel now uh the two leaders Netanyahu
and Biden are clearly at odds over this
what sort of pressure does that actually
put on Netanyahu now
bear in mind this is a long-standing
relationship between American President
Joe Biden and prime minister Benjamin
Netanyahu they've known each other for
40 years by netanyahu's recollection of
the two have not met since Netanyahu has
taken office in December and President
Biden up until Tuesday evening had never
been so clear publicly about his
opposition to the judicial overhaul
though we know from the American Media
that uh Biden the Biden administration
had been pressuring Benjamin Netanyahu
and his administration to calm the
streets to come to some sort of
compromise Netanyahu has saying is
saying that he appreciates the
long-standing alliance between the two
countries he says it's unbreakable and
that they've always been able to
overcome the rare occasions in the past
but he is saying Israel is a sovereign
sovereign country it makes its decision
by the will of the people and not from
pressure from abroad Netanyahu is
sticking to his belief that there is a
need for judicial overhaul he's saying
that this Administration is committed to
strengthening democracy by restoring the
proper balance between the three
branches of government and we're
striving to achieve that via consensus
now if you speak to the opposition they
do not believe even to this moment that
the governing Coalition is sincere about
compromise we only got to this point on
Sunday evening when Netanyahu fired his
defense minister yo AV gallant and that
escalated the situation considerably
just on that point is there an update on
negotiations with the opposition to
resolve this crisis I mean how are they
going
well right now now at the Israeli
president's home here in Jerusalem he is
meeting with members of the opposition
party specifically members representing
Arab political parties on Tuesday
evening for the first time since this
political Crisis began about three
months ago negotiating teams did meet
they met for about an hour there were
members of the governing Coalition and
members of the opposition Israeli
Reports say that there was not much
progress that it was more a setting of
the stage of future negotiations and
there are negotiations planned today as
well but president Herzog said that he
hopes that the negotiations will quote
calm the spirits lower the flames and
lead to positive results with a broad
agreement there is still a lot of anger
and suspicion and there will be more
protests not only
among the opposition but supporters are
also expressing their intent to go to
the streets both sides very entrenched
in their desire to push their each push
their side I will say that we still
don't know what's going on with the
defense minister post now the Sunday
evening Netanyahu did fire joab Gallant
the defense minister but he never
received a formal dismissal letter and
yesterday gallat attended a routine
security meeting and Netanyahu has not
said a word about the defense minister
since then there is a lot of speculation
that perhaps for the time being to calm
the situation that the status quo will
remain in terms of the defense minister
posting and Gallant will remain at his
post okay thank you so much that is
Natasha good night for us in West
Jerusalem